here's the video people are giving her
bad faith advice
people I don't think the audience will
be served at all by hearing this but
I'll play it for you anyway yeah this
thing that like annoys me like well
dating world is like talking
stages like that shit's so annoying like
the whole like
and just like the inconsistency in them
like I literally like hate that like so
much but I think that's like my biggest
thing it's just like what what
specifically just like the fact of just
like you like
I don't know how to word this
so she's saying that the in the early
days when you're texting back and forth
for like and then it turns into a week
of texting and then two weeks so then
she she goes on to say like no one wants
to commit or be in a traditional like
dating right these weird talking stages
and their talking stages mean like the
hook up phase and we're seeing someone
and she's also talking about 21 year old
dudes who go to college in California
like here's here's what James Lindsay
said she's crying for help because of
the damage online dating and hookup
culture have wrought speaking vaguely
and badly about her tacit knowledge of a
miserable you wanna pull that up uh
speaking uh let me start over she's
crying for help because of the damage
online dating and hookup culture have
wrought speaking vaguely and badly about
her tacit knowledge of a miserable
circumstance without the vocabulary to
articulate it this is sad yes what I got
you can see I even I retweeted it too
James is marfella when I got from it is
she's basically like she wants a real
relationship with somebody yes and that
doesn't exist and uh it's feminism's
fault because basically the sexual
Liberation thing told men you have to
you there's nothing you have to do
anymore there's no responsibility
there's no resources there's no hard
work ladies just gonna give it up so
what you end up with a bunch of little
boys who sit around playing video games
all day and don't have to provide
anything women who don't want families
so you so the guy doesn't have to
provide anything and there's no strings
attached in hooking up and now you have
women and I'm not saying every woman I'm
not saying Muslim at least in this case
one woman who is like this sucks yeah
but it's not just I feel like this is a
majority of the Gen Z girls and the the
whatever they're calling that other
generation they really fell prey to this
hookup culture and I think a lot of them
and you see it here in her even though
she's not saying well they're
understanding that it's not making them
happy and that's why I feel if we had
someone that wasn't you know Andrew
Tate's great right the way he articulate
relates this to young men hopefully he's
innocent but he's you know innocent he's
going to be charging well you know you
want to preface it but you know he does
see these good things but we need Andrew
Tate has not been charged with any
crimes yes so it's like what's he's not
even he's not even there's nothing to be
innocent um
that's my little disclaimer but I like
what he has to say but I think there
needs to be a version of that that is
palatable for women that's saying the
same thing but palatable for women
because they feel the same way but the
way that it's put for them is just off I
don't know the only way to to beat it is
to not participate it in it like the
only way to get rid of hookup culture is
to just stop hooking up with people and
I'm sorry but most of the girls on this
podcast on this podcast whatever are
hooking up with people they're making
the problem worse and they're not
willing to take accountability I think
that's why a lot of people are like
angry when they see this clip because
they're like I mean I don't know this
about this girl individually but like
the archetype uh you know she's
contributing to her own problem and also
Andrew Tate is a participant in hookup
culture so it doesn't really resonate
when I hear him talking about the
negative effects he's not like people
say he's kind of like what do they call
him uh kickbox Mai Tai Jordan Peterson
well yeah but isn't Jordan Peterson more
traditionalist and like clean your room
have a family with kids Andrew Tate is
like get all the ladies you know yeah
yeah I guess Peterson walks well
technically Andrew Tate is more
traditional than Jordan Peterson because
Tate brings it back to a you know carnal
more primitive State Peterson says don't
lie and Andrew Tate says I lied for
money I had women pretending to be
talking to guys why dudes doing the
typing we made tons of money we we ran
the game like he's just a liar and proud
about it so they are not on the same
level in any way I agree with you that
being alone is less worse than being
with the wrong person so like these
people doing hookup culture maybe they'd
be better off if they were alone but
those being alone and being in the wrong
relationship are like deem
the alternative isn't even being alone
it's just like dating in a in a normal
way that doesn't immediately like for
these women give strange men access to
your body you know what I think it is
for both sides I think it's a cultural
deficit in that we created all of this
media
iconography TV shows about love at first
sight and about you know a guy meeting a
girl and they just love each other or
Hallmark movies where you know the
woman's in a relationship with the guy
but he's snooty and she goes back to her
hometown and there's the old you know
football player and you know the
Lumberjack The Lumberjack and he's and
he's he's a stand-up honorable guy and
in reality relationships are built
together you you you meet each other you
get along you say okay you start
building things together and you build
up that emotional bond over a long
period of time it's also like young
people seem to think that it's like you
meet someone and it's like they're the
one no met them if you are in your best
place and you meet someone in their best
place then you will realize together
you're something but they're not going
to make you better you gotta you gotta
be up there so that they can come up to
meet you I I made that mistake for a
long time thinking she was gonna fix me
and well so what's advice you guys would
give to young guys because I think a lot
of guys are afraid of rejection sucks
and getting rejected in public if that
gets blasted out on the internet not
only you might even look like a predator
a kids are probably guys are probably
afraid of that so what advice also need
to learn to reject guys in a way that's
gracious and not ruthless you know
that's a problem what would be that's
cool what would be a good like advice
for for young guys that want to
pursue a relationship with the girl in
this modern technology era
that's a very loaded question I mean I
think it depends what they want you know
if you're a young man looking for more
traditional relationship go to church
yeah yeah I mean that's really a lot of
people say that but it's like
okay you're gonna go up to someone in
church and be like hi like that wouldn't
be very trapped make some people feel
weird they say the supermarket I didn't
mean to interrupt you no you're fine but
I I just feel like they have to they
have to live you know you have to walk
the walk and you can't be calling for
traditional Lifestyles if you yourself
are involved in hookup culture and
things like that you know if that's what
you want really Tim's not wrong you're
going to find that in church or a
supermarket that's the other thing no
for real they say you know guys will go
to a bar to pick up chicks and it's just
like I guess that makes sense for a guy
but for for a woman it doesn't make
sense because you're gonna get a guy
who's not looking for any kind of real
relationship that that's what this young
woman is basically saying she comes to a
point in the video where she says like
this is not gonna lead to a real
relationship and then there's another
video going viral of a Japanese woman
who was surprised when she met this
guy's family and she was like so this
guy I've been seeing him we went on five
dates he introduces me to his family and
I'm thinking like wow this is a really
big deal like we're hitting it off and
then when she inquires he's like no no
we're just friends and she was like what
like that doesn't exist where she's from
when a guy and a girl hang out several
times they're dating when they introduce
their families to each other it's very
serious in America dude look the first
thing about feminism I don't know if
Japan has their together either
well sure dating oh yeah absolutely they
have the hickey kimori where the guy
yeah hikikomori the guys locked
themselves in their rooms and play video
games all day and never come out even
when their friends are like outside
there's in their room playing video
games and no one ever sees them and then
uh but that's Japan uh I forgot what I
was gonna say I was gonna say something
about oh yeah feminism
I know that the the woke leftists are
going to be like you know Tim Poole
blames feminism in cell blah blah blah
and it's like look man I don't care
about women running for president I know
we end up like I think actually let me
pause what's your stance in the 19th
Amendment actually repeal
I think there have been a plethora of
problems
there you go we like we have women on
the show and they're like repeal the
19th and it's always the guys who are
like well I don't know I'm like if the
ladies vote for it but anyway I don't
care about that stuff feminism wants to
see women as CEOs I don't care run a
company do whatever you want like I can
choose to go to business do business
with whoever I want you can run a
company if you start a company but in
terms of like the sexual Liberation
stuff it's not really Liberation it's
stripped women of their leverage in
relationships women women were told you
can go around and sleep with whoever you
want and the guys were like yes I love
that you're pointing that out about
leverage because when they call men in
cells they're saying you can't get
access to sex with women but like sex
with women has become valueless now yeah
so where'd the leverage go is that even
an insult anymore well so the thing
about installs is most of these guys
it's an internal problem it's never been
easier for these guys to hook up you go
to a bar buy some drinks everybody gets
you know has a good time they're drunk
they go party and then for or you know
it that's tough that's a risky and
modern culture because you for sure you
blast it out on the Internet it's
putting your hands on someone's thighs
I'm not saying they don't touch women
without consent but they might think
they're it's consensual and then they're
taking a step too far I think that's a
big problem there is a reason why bars
have the lights turned low and there's a
reason why there's that that you can
bite it like Hot Topic or Spencer's or
whatever it says beer making ugly people
attractive since you know like 900 like
is it I've always thought the one of the
cringiest things of the guy's like can I
kiss you now and they're like oh God
just go for it
so should the guy ask before he makes a
move I I don't think it should be
but I think whoa
absolutely they have to
see see that women women
that want that lady cop yeah you guys
okay so we were talking I should pull
this up because this is actually perfect
I don't even know how do I how do I look
this story back I had it pulled up and
I'm like okay
she was emotionally groomed guys thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time